[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je suis brésilien j'ai de l'or et
j'arrive de R de J plus riche
aujourd'hui que nager Paris je te
reviens encore deux fois je suis venu
déjà j'is de l'or dans ma valise des
chemise combien a duré tout cela le
temps d'avoir 200 amis et de mes 4 5 M 6
mois de galantes IVR c'est plus rien en
Paris Paris on si moi tu m'as tout raflé
puis vers ma jeune amère que tu ma
pauvre mélancolique délicatement emballé
mais je brûlais de revenir et là-bas s
mon ciel sauvage je me répéteis avec
rage une autre fortune en Mouré je ne
suis pas mort j'ai gagné tant bien comm
mal de Somme folé je viens pour que tu
me voles t ce que là-bas j'ai volé tout
ce que là-bas j'ai volé tout ce que
là-bas j'ai vol
je suis brésilien j'ai de l'or et
j'arrive de R de TI plus riche
aujourd'hui que ner Paris je te reviens
encore je suis brésilien je de l'or et
j'arrive de Rio de Janel Paris Paris
Paris Paris je te reviens encore HRA HRA
HRA je viens de débarquer mettez vos
faux cheveux COCOT HRA HRA HRA j'apporte
à vosotes toute une fortune à croqué le
pigeon vient plus mais plusumett prenez
mes dollars bannes m montre mon chapeau
mes botes mais dites-moi que vous
m'aimez à moi les jeus les ris et les
danses
cavalières à moi les nuits de Paris
comme M en bal d'ère sache-le bien
seulement car c'est là ma nature j'en
prendrai pour mon argent je vous le
jure j'en prendrai pour mon argent j'en
prendrai pour mon argent venez venez
venez
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
venez